Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, I want to continue
reminding you. There are people pretending to
be me trying to scam you on YouTube. Here is
a new scam involving P.S. Fives, PlayStation
fives. I think these are I think the five is
the newest one. Is it? I don't know. I've
never owned a PlayStation. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Yes, my name is Brenda, and
I listen to you show a lot. And somebody
contacted me saying through you right, that I
won PlayStation five, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. No. And my I.D. has been ripped off
a lot, so I did not give him my address.
Good. And I just want to know if it's real.
Speaker 1: No, it is not real. Okay. So I've
told you many times before, I don't want you
to text me, okay? If you if you comment on on
YouTube and then it looks like I'm saying, hey,
cool, please text me. It's not me. All right.
I don't want to chat with you on WhatsApp. If
you're getting responses on YouTube saying David,
saying sir or ma'am, I'm David, please chat with
me on WhatsApp. It's not me and I am not giving
away any PlayStation fives. I'm not giving
away game boys. Commodore 60 fours Xboxes
Xbox three sixties Super Nintendo. Nintendo
Genesis. I'm not giving away JAG. You are Jaguar,
however. Okay, I'm not. I have no Atari's
or video game consoles to give away.
These are scams. One thing that is upsetting
me. The people that are being targeted. We've
been investigating this, the people being targeted
in my YouTube comments. Oftentimes they will say
in their comments, their age, and it's usually
above 65. So there are now five people who were
targeted by these scammers on YouTube who in their
comment said, David, I'm 68 and I watch you every
day. Boom. Thank you so much for your comment.
I'd like you to text me. Next thing you know,
they're getting scammed. So few things here.
Maybe don't post your age in the comments.
I don't need to know your age when you leave
a comment. I'm not text. Just don't respond,
folks. Report them. We're reporting them as
quickly as we can. But these are scams. I'm
not looking to give away anything. All right.
Please, please, please. On today's bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money and everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Producer Pat was sent my pillow pillows
and he is going to review them. There's a
whole back story to how he ended up with
the pillows instead of me. Okay, we're going
to get to that number two. One vote made a
difference in a massachusetts House election
after a recount. One vote had been miscounted
and it changed the winner. Amazon is being
accused of stealing tips from delivery drivers
and the baby whose parents didn't want the baby to
get, quote, vaccinated blood if necessary during a
lifesaving heart surgery has had the life saving
heart surgery. We will tell you what happened,
what went down. It's an incredible story.
But the good news is the baby had the
procedure. All of those stories and more on
today's bonus show. It's really easy to get
access to the bonus show. Just sign up at join
Packman dot com. You can use the coupon code
please no more Trump and you have to say it
with that tone when you type it in Please no
more Trump. That's the code you save. You become
a member. It's an amazing thing and I will see
you on the bonus show in mere moments. Otherwise,
we'll be back tomorrow with another new episode.